[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the fabled patronus charm
and none other than dolores umbridge
dolores umbridge stole the hearts of
many young fans
during her introduction to the franchise
immediately being conveyed as a kind
fair woman who always looked after
harry's best interests
okay so something's wrong with the above
statement
right the issue with dolores umbridge's
character is that despite the fact that
she was a cruel
evil woman with nothing but male intent
running through her veins
she was still somehow able to cast a
patronus charm i've seen so many of you
asking for this video
particularly as i've been covering
patronuses quite a bit lately and the
question i'm going to be answering is
how could dolores umbridge cast a
patronus charm
there's no explicit canon answer for
this question but i think that we have
more than enough information to theorize
first of all we need to dive into
umbridge's past to get a better sense of
her overall character
when we're first introduced to umrich
she's supposedly 30-something
so maybe just maybe there has been a
point in her history when she wasn't
quite so awful
dolores umbridge was a british
half-blood witch born in the year 1965
or potentially a bit earlier given that
she was a half-blood which is
interesting given her perspective on
blood purity
it goes without saying that she had one
muggle and one magical parent
her father was a wizard by the name of
orford umbridge and her mother was
muggle ellen cracknell
she even had a younger brother whose
name is never revealed that was born a
squib
scribbs are non-magical people born into
a wizarding family
dolores family life was complicated and
her family was the source of much shame
for her
her father orford was a floor mopper at
the ministry of magic where dolores
would later work
you can only imagine what she thought of
that her father also blamed her mother
for birthing a squib
this was a toxic matter that really
divided the family
and led to dolores eventual loathing of
her mother she hated her just because
she was muggleborn
her own mother does that remind you of a
certain someone and their father
the constant tension inside the walls of
the family's home eventually meant that
everyone would part ways
the magical side of the family dolores
and her father continued to live in the
wizarding world
while the non-magical side ellen and her
son moved to the muggle world
this didn't happen until dolores was 15
years old but it has been expressed that
neither side of the family ever saw the
other again
just like everyone else when she was 11
she began attending hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
and was sorted into nadanza in southern
house before heading off to school
she traveled to olivanders to have her
one selected and she was a recipient of
a notably short wand
an eight-inch birch wand with a dragon
heartstring core
ollivander has expressed in the past
that the length of a witch or wizards
wand
can be an indicator of their moral
character so i can only begin to imagine
what this says about umbridge
most ones are between 9 and 15 inches
long wand makers often match the one
length
to the height of the witch or wizard who
will use it but ollivander considers
this measure
inadequate in his experience longer than
average ones
tend to be drawn to those with a
physical peculiarity or a bigger
personality
whereas abnormally short ones select
people whose character lacks in
something
when she finally got to school her head
of house was horus slughorn
slughorn disliked umbridge almost
immediately and has even referred to her
as
an idiotic woman for this reason despite
her being a massive keener
he never rewarded her with any position
of power i think that slughorn could see
right through her
but never being appointed as prefect or
head girl in her house despite wanting
it more than anything
only added fuel to the fire for umbrage
as her career at the ministry of magic
exploded after her graduation
by age 30 umbridge even managed to
secure a position
as head of the improper use of magic
office the perfect posting
for a deranged stickler for the rules by
the time the 1995-96 school year came
around we had just recently been
introduced to umbridge
and at that time the ministry of magic
put out a statement expressing they were
unimpressed with the slipping standards
of hogwarts
this statement was the result of a
fearful minister of magic fudge
lashing out he was blinded by fear and
in utter denial that the dark lord
voldemort had returned
fudge was punishing dumbledore who was
so strongly trying to convince him of
the truth
and despite dumbledore's continuous
attempts to convince fiji of the truth
he was still eventually stripped of his
title as head master of hogwarts
in place of dumbledore the ministry of
magic appointed dolores umbridge
who in that same school year worked as
the defense against the dark arts
professor
as well as the hogwarts high inquisitor
during her time at hogwarts she had
enormous power of the students
teachers curriculum grounds and
basically everything
for the duration that she was there she
made the lives of the students
increasingly miserable
she did everything wrong she would
conduct unreasonable and abusive
punishments
as we see in the i will not tell lies
seen in the order of phoenix
she would speak to students and staff
members condescendingly and she was just
awful
so this pretty much covers umbridge's
backstory it doesn't look like there is
a whole lot of good in her past
everything about her history points to
her dubious morality
she blindly hated her own mother and
brother was massively disappointed in
her own father
was selected for a wand below the normal
minimum length
and couldn't even impress her head of
house despite doing everything she could
it seems like umbrage was just rotten to
the core which is extra confusing to me
given that she was able to cast her own
patronus charm the patronus charm is
famous
for its representation of light
happiness and purity
and it's produced when a witcher wizard
cast the spell expecto patronum
there are two types of petronas charms
corporeal and incorporeal
and the type that the witch or wizard
casts will depend on their experience or
preference the more basic form of the
spell is the incorporeal patronus
which assumes no animal form and simply
resembles a burst of white vapor or
smoke and the more advanced form of the
spell is the conjuring of a corporeal
patronus
it's a hard spell to cast on a technical
level but the hardest part about it
is mustering the necessary emotion to
cast it not just anyone can do it
and it's been widely accepted that most
dark witches and wizards just don't have
it in them
in fact rowling revealed in an interview
that severus snape was the only death
eater that could ever produce one
given that dementor is the primary
creature that you'd want to ward off
with a patronus charm
i guess it makes sense that dark witches
and wizards wouldn't need to be able to
produce one
they're sort of on the same side but i
can also imagine umbridge
wanting to be protected at all costs
particularly as she works so closely
with dementors
umbridge after all was the one who
notoriously sent dementors to little
whinging to attack harry potter
but again how can she cast one how is
that even possible
we talked time and time again that it's
a skill reserved for the pure of heart
we even learned of what happens to
wizards that aren't pure of heart who
tried to produce it
in the tale of rexidian who was eaten
alive by maggots
unbridge was sick and twisted just like
any other witch or wizard
so what gives the following excerpt from
pottermore sheds some light on this
and i believe that what it comes down to
is umbridge's own sense of righteousness
while there is widespread and justified
belief that the wizard who is not pure
of heart
cannot produce a successful patronus the
most famous example of the spellback
firing is that of the darkwizard
brixidian who was devoured by maggots
a rare few witches and wizards of
questionable morals have succeeded in
producing the charm
dolores umbridge for example is able to
conjure a cat patronus to protect
herself from dementors
it continues it may be that a true and
confident belief
in the rightness of one's actions can
supply the necessary happiness
however most such men and women who
become desensitized to the effects of
the dark creatures with whom they may
ally themselves
regard the patronus as an unnecessary
spell to have in their arsenal
what this suggests about the patronus
charm is that if the witch or wizard's
moral compass is so broken and twisted
that they have deluded themselves into
thinking that they're doing the right
thing
then there is no reason that they
wouldn't be able to cast patronus
producing a patronus requires good and
happy thoughts
and to umbridge law and order were happy
thoughts
in a way she was sociopathic because she
had a fundamental inability
to understand the empathy or emotions of
others she was focused only on
her own objectives and even by doing bad
things she was able to convince herself
that she was doing the right thing
umbridge genuinely felt that her actions
were contributing towards the greater
good
and for that reason she could do it she
could cast a patronus
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think why did you think umbridge
could cast patronus
let me know down in the comments section
below until next time
you're a wizard howdy